hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
just checking in to see how your week's
going if you're watching this i don't
know if you're listening to it or
watching it we have a special guest
every once in a while
um i come out of my shell
and i talk to somebody that i i admire
let me give you a huge build up here
because i know it's gonna make you
uncomfortable that i just i'm such a
huge fan of his stand-up and now is
acting star
and co-writer of the louis ck movie
fourth of july we have the one and only
the content king i believe he's called
joe list everybody that's me thanks
everybody it's always a moment because i
actually paused for like applause like i
kind of felt like there was going to be
like laws
and there was nothing
um let's just cut to the chase all right
i'm not going to be one of these [ __ ]
interviewers that just glances at your
wikipedia page and goes oh see you grew
up in marblehead or whatever
i actually watched the movie downloaded
it off of louie's site only 15 bucks
um to a great cause what a [ __ ] great
movie a great cause a great cause yeah a
filmmaker
as opposed to you know getting it for
free
um dude i absolutely
loved
that movie i thought it was such
heartfelt you know tugged at the hot
strings it was hilarious it was like
dark the way it was shot the soundtrack
and your performance dude you're a
[ __ ] great actor oh thank you well i
was playing myself and my story about my
life but i mean i keep saying this i'm
like i feel like if i played like a
british soldier in the uh revolutionary
war they'd be like that guy sucks oh
yeah so you're saying you're like eminem
an eight mile yeah i'm like you know
it's but then and louie's so kind he's
like no it's actually harder to play
yourself and i'm like no it's
for sure not well maybe it's like you're
you're in your head and i got to give
shout outs to all the people that tony v
yeah tony was great uh nick depaolo lynn
kopolitz and robert walsh who plays your
dad who uh i'm trying not to give away
too much of it but it has very few lines
but what he
communicates with his face
was uh
incredible and there was just that's one
of those movies you got to watch like 10
times because there's so many quotable
lines as you're going through the
emotion of of the movie that like
lynn tony and and who was the guy who
played like your uncle
uh and you had that big the big scene in
the kitchen oh chris walsh who's a
comedian and uh he's like a sketch
improv actor and stand-up he lives in
l.a he's great that scene was just it
was just a it was amazing bobby kelly
what am i saying yeah bobby kelly
um he was awesome all those guys were
awesome it was it was amazing yeah yeah
alan havey all of these guys so it's
great to see a bunch of comedians uh
acting their asses off the movie is
called fourth of july and you can get it
off of louis ck's uh website
and uh what is it what was it four stars
is the best five stars
uh wait what do you mean as far as the
movie writing thing you're a movie some
people do five some people do roger
always did four and i always thought
five made more sense because four is too
little so i say five stars well he ate
too much at the dinner table so he had
to cut back somewhere you cut back on
the stars not on the calories
uh but i'm starting to get back in shape
so i'm gonna go five stars on that just
as far as like uh it was so fun i hated
how relatable your character was oh
thank you i was hoping that you know
you're related i feel like we we
probably come from similar families
right we grew up a couple towns apart
big irish families oh dude the
awkwardness it's just basically it's the
classic uh
you know emotionally
abusive family with there's like all of
this in uh love
where it's
expressed through food
but never spoken right and like the love
is implied
and and then like hugging is just like
the
i mean eye contact it feels like too
intimate when if you're actually
talking about stuff in in family
dynamics like that but like if you're
talking sports or arguing it's like
total eye contact with dude you're out
of your [ __ ] mind like that is just
totally locked in but if you're gonna
say a sorry if that even happens or any
sort of like uh
expression of love
it's all like yeah dude whatever i'm not
gonna get all [ __ ] gay here he always
goes homophobic or [ __ ] just
immediately just like goes off the rails
and um
all right that's i'm going to be done
gushing over because i'm going to give
away the movie but like uh
i watched it i'm going to watch it again
uh tonight uh with my wife uh it's how
much i enjoyed it
thank you gosh gush away please yeah
it's fantastic so let's get into uh
some of the other some of your other
irons that you have in the fire
you talented young man oh thank you yeah
dude your stand-up is like i follow you
on instagram and like
and the [ __ ] that you post they're just
they're all a-level jokes they're just
bangers and i was wondering like how are
you not slowly eating away at your hour
for your next special as you're
posting these things that's all from my
last hour so i did two hours sort of
back to back-ish once right before covet
hit i did a special called i hate myself
these are all on youtube please watch
them uh it's i hate myself and then i
did another one right after covet sort
of ended called this year's material and
so i've been posting all those but you
have to post so much goddamn [ __ ] now
right that um i just keep posting the
special because i'm like i don't a lot
of people do like crowd work [ __ ] i
don't do that much crowd work so i can't
post you don't need to you you got the
you got you have ideas that you want to
get out of your uh on your head i'm
really bad about uh
posting stuff too every once in a while
i guess i like
i think you can just sort of like rant
about stuff i see people do
things like that but there is also
something to be said that if you don't
post a lot yeah
like people are like oh yeah i think
it's almost like you can go one way or
the other you're either gonna just
hammer him every day or every once in a
while you stop in and people are just
like it was nice that he visited right
it was good it was good to see him again
well it's so confused you need like a
[ __ ] phd to be a comedian now i mean
when i started i i hate to sound like
old school boomer i'm like let me just
work on the act i'll listen to sets i'll
write new now it's like you got a
hashtag people are like you gotta post
at 8am you posted at 9am what are you a
[ __ ] idiot and i'm like oh i didn't
know and then one time i posted
something like bombed it didn't get any
likes so i took it down someone's like
oh you can't take it down that [ __ ] up
your algorithm and i'm like i
i gotta study out is that like if you
cancel a credit card it hurts your
credit i guess evidently i have no idea
and like some i released the special on
youtube this year's material and like it
did well got a million views and it's
sort of like puttered and then this guy
messaged me was like dude you let your
special die you should have been posting
clips that's all i think about i go to
bed i'm like i guess i let it die i
didn't know i was supposed to do more
than just put it out and go on podcast i
feel like what comedians do now is like
what bands and rappers have been used to
do when there was uh or still do but
like i remember early on
um
when i got into music and stuff and i
would listen to like like bands like
motley crue talking about like how they
made it and they'd have they booked
themselves in a club and they would they
would put flyers up on every tree they
could find they'd have everybody come
down there and then all these rappers
talking about you know we'd make these
mixed tapes and we'd just sell them out
of the trunk of the car and just try to
and hopefully people make copies of them
and get it going like that grassroot way
or like uh
i remember the comedian talent he would
be doing uh caroline's he'd have like a
street team handing out flyers in times
square and that type of stuff and i feel
like you guys
um do the same thing now but you can do
it literally on a global level
with um
with like the internet so
everything that you just said i i don't
know
any of that like i don't know when
you're supposed to post about letting a
special die like i feel like you put it
out there and then word of mouth
and and it it gets out there i guess
yeah that that you know when you post it
i feel like people are on their phones
all day long like i don't think if you
post it at nine as opposed to eight i do
remember that in radio though we got to
get you on during morning drive
everybody shuts the radio off between 8
30 and 9. that made sense back in the
day but i think what happens is so much
stuff is being posted that yours gets
buried if you post it at 11 a.m all the
stuff that was posted from 8am to 11am
i'm guessing here i'm just taken from
what i've heard because people now it's
like you gotta be like a farmer you
gotta wake up at five
before the sun to post your 30 second
clip of calling a woman in the audience
a dyke because if you don't get it out
there it's not gonna be seen
i feel like that's um
there's merit and all of that but then
there's also at some point you have to
have belief
in your talent that the cream is gonna
rise
to to the top and like that you don't
have to like
you know there's a balance between
creating and promoting right and i feel
like when you're more about pro like
something's gonna
hurt and i would rather have it be the
promotion and have somebody discover
something of quality that maybe i could
have promoted better than to become more
of like uh this website guy or whatever
this uh algorithm guy
um um
i don't know i i have that's that's
probably
my old generation way of looking things
which by the way how how annoying
is my generation as far as saying you
kids today you know back in the day we
had a [ __ ] make vhs tapes
do stand up in the snow it's very
annoying the most annoying thing from
your generation is that maybe you're a
little bit later than this a lot of
these guys started in like the 80s where
they're like yeah my [ __ ] third year
of doing comedy i made six hundred
thousand dollars and i'm like well that
was 1988 like i started in 2003. there
wasn't like a lot of these guys started
in the comedy boom right and six months
in you were doing 50 weeks on the road i
started in 2003 and like there was like
11 comedy clubs left nobody cared about
comedy
yeah i went through two of those i
started
in 92 so the whole cokehead hangover of
the 80s like every guy that i opened for
like
most of them that i opened for in boston
would start off saying like their
opening line was like you know so i've
been sober for a year and a half and
there was a couple of them they
literally were getting their wages
garnished
by the irs because they got paid in cash
and literally cocaine right in the 80s
and then all of a sudden all of those
club owners got pinched and then they
just ran well i gave this guy this and i
gave that guy that and i just like well
we don't and then they would go to them
and uh like i knew this comic like he
would have to contact the irs to do a
gig in atlantic city or vegas and let
him know that he was you know leaving
this the uh the state or whatever so
then when i came down to new york
it was this amazing creative time but
like dude the seller there would be like
nobody there and they didn't bark at all
like you do the seller if you can
believe this yeah there would be like
three
to [ __ ] 20 people in the crowd like
20 would be like decent and you wanted
to go on early if you went on late like
i was getting like dude you'd go up in
front of [ __ ] nobody and then i
always give this guy credit louis
shaffer not gay louis shaffer that was
his that was his thing he's in england
now he was the guy that started
debarking in the village and got
everybody doing it at all the clubs oh
wow and uh he first started doing it at
the boston comedy club and he would just
[ __ ] pack the place because he didn't
want to go on in front of nobody and he
just took the initiative and he had this
disarming thing he had like a sport coat
he had loafers with white socks and
these jeans and a dress shirt like
tucked in he'd be like you know like
there'd be like he'd be like beautiful
black ladies beautiful black place they
would turn around he was like this
character with like he had like the horn
room glasses louis schaefer not gay
stand-up comedy lovely ladies lovely
ladies love comedy and they would just
have him laughing and then like he would
get enough of them coming in and then he
started
doing the seller and ever since then
the seller was doing that it used to be
like you had to be in the know and it
was like nyu kids mixed with confused
european tourists who would go in there
hearing laughter and that's what you
like performed to and
the next lull
was uh
it kind of came back and then went down
sometime again in the 90s
and then
9 11
right brought everybody out everybody
stayed inside for like a month and was
like depressed as [ __ ] at least in new
york and then they just came out in
droves and wanted to laugh again and uh
and i've it's been on like this
this [ __ ] ridiculous like ponzi
scheme uptick
for like 20 years and i i just keep
thinking there's no way how long can
this go
but what it is is i think that stand-up
comedy is perfect for like the internet
generation where they just want
something new they want something new
they want something new and because of
what we do you can only tell a joke once
and put it out there right you can't do
it again so we we're kind of built
for like what it is but uh
that's funny though
that's first of all it's funny that you
thought i started in the 80s
well i guess i was more talking about i
don't want to name names but you know
depaolo and all these guys they started
i worked with depaulo for years and he's
like yeah he showed me his book from
like his second year of comedy and there
was like eight comedy clubs in boston he
did like 4 000 sets like my second year
of comedy i did like 60 sets part of
that's my own laziness alcoholism right
but like i just did wednesdays at chomps
lounge in boston and i was like that's
what i would do and then someone finally
after a year was like how come i don't
see it in any of the rooms and i was
like i didn't know there were other
rooms i was just doing this one but i
feel like in the 80s i hate drinking to
do in sports to watch but in the 80s you
know it's like there was
boston had six clubs and then there was
all those road rooms which i did some of
those rooms the vfws and the firehouses
and stuff but
for a while you could do
a ton of work like a year two years into
comedy
yeah i missed that i missed that so it
was uh by the time i got in it was
nick's comedy stop and the uh comedy
connection yeah
and then just like satellite rooms and
uh
and i don't know i don't know what it's
weird because because like i didn't
start that much longer like you were
like eight years in when i started i
started in 2000 which to me
when you start someone that's doing
comedy eight years feels like this
crafty old veteran yeah and now looking
back you're like that's not even that
long
no no i was still uh on any given night
eight years and at any given night i
could just go sideways so i used to get
real nervous because i
it was just one of those i just had a
tiger by the tail he was going up there
like i don't know how to control this i
know how to do it a little bit but like
you know
i compare it to learning how to fly once
you learn how to do a little something
you can fly it but if you run into some
turbulence
you know you need the instructor to take
control or whatever uh that was kind of
the way it was but there was nobody to
throw it to
and uh yeah i would routinely uh you
know i would say once every
10 days
i would have a set where i was just like
i'd have to shake it off i would
question why i ever thought i was i
would do this thing and that was like
[ __ ] eight years in that's also why
you know a lot of people
wisely never decide to do this but how
long do you think before you kind of
wrangled it where you can kind of go up
and you could follow somebody
um you you could you know
you could have a nice long break before
you took one it's hard because
first of all doesn't it feel like you
always think you're pretty good and
stand up like when i was like a year in
i was like i'm pretty good i'm better
than a lot of these guys that are also
here and then when you look back you're
like i was horrendous like there's not a
time
where i in the moment i was like i suck
i mean there was nights where you're
like i suck but overall you're like i'm
pretty good and then sometimes i eat it
but looking back you're like that [ __ ]
was terrible which makes me feel like
i'm gonna look back now and be like that
was [ __ ] horrible that whole special
yeah but if that if you're growing
that's the way it's gonna be right now
but you're also were comparing yourself
to like other open micros like that's
the first group you have to become in
the upper echelon right of open micros
and then you become an opener
and then there's that mountain you gotta
climb and then um uh
middler which is what they called it in
boston it somehow became a feature
but right middle act
and uh and then like headlining or
whatever like outside rooms
and and all of that but like i
i think like your generation like what
you guys i mean it started dane cook was
the guy that kind of broke it open like
what you could do
with like the internet right and um
then i i think uh like the next guy i
remember was bo burnham
where he wrote all of these comedy songs
and like one of his first weekends was
going clean
selling out the comedy connection of
faneuil hall and i was just like dude
like i don't know what that is but
that's the [ __ ] way to do that like
if if
you can like somehow like
not have to go through all of this other
[ __ ] and you know how to promote
yourself i thought it was awesome and
there was definitely
you know people that were were upset by
like you got to pay your dues you got to
get slapped around and [ __ ] and it's
just kind of like well do you well that
[ __ ] held me back and bought because i
was in boston i started in boston also
and i was there for seven years and then
i kept going back when i first moved to
new york because i became like a guy in
boston i moved to new york and so like
every other weekend i'd be like i'm
gonna go back to boston where i kind of
i'm somebody yeah but that boston thing
i remember being like two or three years
in i was like a teenager and they would
be like so and so he says he has an hour
he doesn't have an hour you don't have
an hour after two years [ __ ] that and so
i kept being like oh [ __ ] i must only
have 10 minutes like it made me
it put that like you pay dues you hang
out for 20 years thing that was like so
deeply in my head and it definitely held
me back because i kept thinking like i
shouldn't have any success seven years
in
like some truth to it and then it gets
to the point where it like holds you
back right i had the same thing while
all of that [ __ ] down the cellar was
sitting around we trash each other at
the table and take a trash and and learn
how to take a pounding it would yeah it
made you tougher on stage and all of
that [ __ ] but in the end
it
it was really negative right right
it was kind of like your family in the
fourth of july where it's like there's
ball breaking until
it's like it it's not ball breaking
anymore it's just we're all just
grabbing each other's coattails and
yanking you back to the starting line
like when i look back at those
the the level of talent that was at that
table and how we didn't create one
[ __ ] thing we didn't even shoot a
sketch right we did nothing and it was
some of the [ __ ] funniest people i've
ever met in my life and all we did was
we used all of our talent to just
[ __ ] destroy each other and you know
it's really been you know in a way sort
of uh turned into like this fairy tale
like this myth type of thing but when i
look back on it it was just like what
you were talking about with there was
a part where you needed to go through it
and then you're just like i'm in this
too long and i also feel like that's the
thing where like starting off in boston
is great and then there's a point where
you're there too long right you go to
new york
and um
there's that point where you got to make
it this i feel you're going to make a
decision am i going to stay in new york
or am i going to go to la and like
me staying in new york was just like i
just could not get any [ __ ] traction
out there
and uh coming out here which i never
thought after living out here i never
thought i would come out here again and
i came out here and that's when
you know uh
[ __ ] like started to happen but um what
all right they finally made some
backyard equipment for the the star of
spaghetti western
solo stove huh are you that bad boy
james dean character that comes in town
who wants to feel warm by a fire but
doesn't want to have to [ __ ] strike a
couple of pieces of flint together
um
solo stove you know there's something
special about fall that brings us closer
together and with the smokeless fire pit
from solo stove creating those moments
is easier than ever enjoy all the warmth
and comfort of a fire pit plus
portability quick setup and cleaning and
best of all no smoke summer may uh
summer may get all the excitement but
nothing beats the great outdoors during
the fall make the most of your outdoor
time this season with solo stove
smokeless portable fire pits that are
easy to set up and clean and right now
it's october right [ __ ] halloween's
coming up you make some pumpkin bread
you take your wife out there you get the
fire going she eats a couple of sweets
maybe she wants an eclair for a [ __ ]
dessert if you know what i mean
um
why is your dick and e clear cause
there's cream inside
oh jesus uh
make most of your outdoor time this
season with solo stove smokeless
portable fire pits that makes it very
easy to clean and set up upgrade your
backyard with a solo stove fire pit and
create story worthy moments without
fireside fumes stainless steel
conduction construction designed to
regulate airflow and burn more more
efficiently so little smoke
you'll wonder if there's even a fire
uh solo stove fire pits are brill
brilliantly engineered be help if i
could [ __ ] read huh to be easy to use
and they're built to last prepare for
your best outdoor memories yet and save
big during the solo stove uh fall event
plus use promo code bur at solostove.com
for an extra ten dollars off and if you
act now they'll add a little person in
there to light it for you
um that's solo
solo stuff.com i don't know why i
picture them coming in with a little top
hat promo just you know like you know
when they send a ship off when they
[ __ ] crash the uh the champagne
bottle they have a little person come in
with a little [ __ ] flick and he
lights it you know and then sings
something from the gershwin catalog
uh that's solostove.com promo code burr
for ten dollars off on the top of the
fall on top of the fall event deals
hurry the fall ends november 10th
uh it's a great thing to get if you
watch college football outside with your
flat screen as the months start to get a
little colder
all right
here's something that i am not a policy
genius
all right why get life insurance
we pay hundreds of dollars per you know
why because you're trying to make a
funny youtube video and you're probably
gonna die and you're gonna leave your
[ __ ] family penniless all right we
pay hundreds of dollars per year to
protect our own homes our cars and even
our phones but too many of us aren't
taking steps to protect our family
finances well that's because you love
your car and your phone you know
your car and your phone never holds you
accountable for your actions does it uh
mortgage payments private student loans
and other types of debt don't just
disappear if something happens to you
[ __ ] heartless bankers right a life
insurance policy can provide your loved
ones with the financial cushion that
they can use to cover their costs and it
can provide you with peace of mind that
even in a worst-case scenario they'll be
protected you know i have a wonderful uh
one of those one of those [ __ ] uh
dystopian tales of people having to hunt
each other they should just have one
where it's just
people in debt hunting down bankers
um because your uncle died and all of a
sudden you you owe the money for his
above ground pool
um worried about price by making it easy
to compare your options from top
companies policy genius can help you can
help make sure you're not paying a cent
more than you have to for the coverage
you need here's how it works policy
genius is an insurance marketplace that
makes it easy to compare quotes from top
companies like aig
that's a top company didn't they [ __ ]
throw this country into financial ruin
and prudential
in one place to find your lowest price
on life insurance you can save
uh up to 50 or more in life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
options start at just 17 per month for
500 grand of coverage can you believe
the [ __ ] arrogance that there can
still still considered a top company aig
just click the link
top serial killers like william [ __ ]
h gacy just click the link in the
description or head to policygenius.com
to get personalized quotes in minutes
and find the right policy for your needs
you like that little wink to the camera
that's adding personality it's priceless
uh the license agents at policy genius
work for you not the insurance company
they're on hand through the entire
process to help you understand your
options so you can make decisions with
confidence uh your personal uh info is
private policy genius doesn't uh get to
sell you doesn't sell your in uh your
details to third parties so head to
policy policygenius.com if you're dumb
like me this is how you spell it p o l i
c y
g e n i u s dot com
uh to get your free life insurance
quotes and see how much you could save
that's it folks
that is the advertising and let's get
back to my wonderful guest
how did you go like at what point
like who came up with the idea for this
movie uh fourth of july and when did you
sit down and write it how long did that
whole process take we so we were louie
and i are buddies and we always talk
movies we're big movie guys and um we
would always talk
[ __ ] about movies and then during the
pandemic i had an idea for a movie that
i was sort of like pitching him and it
was like a horror movie about anxiety
and it was this sort of whole other
thing and i just started writing it and
then at one point he read through it we
read it together we read the whole
script and he kind of gave me notes and
it was like maybe we'll work together on
this but it just kind of fell apart
and then
we started talking again about a move
and i really wanted to make a movie and
that's all we ever talk about is movies
so
we started
kind of just kicking around ideas and he
called me it's a funny story told a
couple places but he called me one day
and he was like i think i thought of
what i'm gonna do next
and he pitched this movie to me it was
like a musical a mamma mia type musical
but for bad company
and it was gonna be all the music of bad
companies like there's gonna be the guy
like brushing his hair in the morning in
the shower and it was like a
30-minute pitch
on like a sunday afternoon and i'm like
i guess this is my day just listening to
louie talk about
his bad company i immediately thought at
the beginning of saturday night fever
when when travolta's getting ready yeah
don't touch the head
i work very hard on my hair and he hits
it yeah um but anyway so he pitched the
whole thing and i went yeah i i don't
know man i just don't think you're gonna
do this it doesn't seem good and in my
mind i'm like the budget to get the
music you're gonna do musi this is
insane oh yeah and i kind of said well
maybe if you'd called me with like a
black and white murder mystery or
something and then he was like hmm black
and white murder mystery and i felt like
i had him on the hook
because now now we're talking movies and
so we started
kind of talking ideas from movies and
then he had this idea about a married
couple that's been together for a long
time
and uh he sort of had an accurate he him
and this actress would play it that was
sort of his idea and he's like i don't
really have a plot this is just this
idea i haven't seen an old married
couple
and then i jotted down this idea i've
had for a long time because everyone in
my generation goes to therapy
and the therapist says you got to
confront your parents it's your parents
and my thought for the movie was what
happens to these parents that are in
their 60s and their 40-year-old son goes
hey
i paid a
old jewish man to tell me that you
ruined my life right and then the kid
leaves and the two parents are left to
be like what the [ __ ] was that that was
insane i thought we did so that was sort
of the idea i jotted down on a piece of
paper like confronting parents what's
next and so we started talking that and
originally it was going to be sort of
like a
uh like a affluent manhattanite family
and then we just started writing it and
just felt like why don't we make it like
a blue-collar boston family because
that's what him and i both are
and then it just became why don't we
just make it my
story you write what you know whatever
so that's how it started we just kind of
started working that and then louie
really developed that mother carry my
mother i i take every opportunity in
public to say my mother is nothing like
the woman you'll see in the film oh i
didn't think that but i know why people
have people would think that oh my god
yeah she's like sociopathic so louis
sort of created this mother character
based on like a conglomerate of of
boston women so he wrote that
character and we just kind of used a lot
of the stuff from my
therapy and we just started putting the
pieces together and we wrote it pretty
quick we kind of just talked it all out
and put it on a chalkboard and then went
through the whole thing and louis had
said if we finish writing this script
we'll make the movie so i was like great
motivated yeah yeah and it's sort of we
sort of just ripped through it and the
whole time it was like
god i hope he doesn't lose interest in
this and he didn't fortunately and
this was all written during covert 2020
2020 we shot this in 2021 on a map yeah
it was sort of it was 2021 so it was
still coverty like you forget that like
february 2021 it was still pretty
cozy
i'm not wearing a mask screaming and
yelling yeah so we wrote it in march and
april of 2021 that we shot it in august
and september like the whole thing
because there's no industry involved we
didn't pitch to anybody there's no
studio or anything it's all louie it's
his money
we
first conversation was like february
28th and we wrapped on september 10th
that's like all in from like pitch
writing
production holy the whole thing yes
that's insane i mean if you take
how long finishing ideas
really speed up the process no but
pre-production is oh my god trying to
cast everybody how relieved are you when
you cast everybody's cast you're like oh
thank god well a lot of that we had like
tony v we had wrote it with tony v in
mind and then um bobby was always going
to be bobby and bill chef's character
was always going to be bill
so we really only had to cast like a
couple people the parents the woman
naomi who's the black girl who's amazing
and then
to paula the guy depalo's character
we actually didn't have nick in mind
originally and we auditioned a few
people
and they all were kind of older they
looked older like and i thought well
this guy i would just beat the [ __ ] out
of this guy this is like an old man
calling me a [ __ ] like why would i
just well i was like we need someone
intimidating we kind of had this moment
of like oh this is nick yeah it's nick
depaulo who's 60 but ripped and covered
in tattoos and nick was just amazing and
and he improvised so many lines that are
so funny god
that that him and tony talking about
jazz i'm not going to say the joke
like all of that [ __ ] just
there was um
you guys you just the tone of it was
perfect where it was like i i'm glad i
wasn't in that house and i wished i was
at the same time because there was so
much
fun
combined with tox
toxicity and like so much like just the
ball breaking and the drinking and the
eating and and talking about sports
combined with just all of this sadness
and and despair and it's just like if
everybody just pushed through this
invisible thing
like this this could be like uh
so much more healthier and it's really
like i found through like um
you know taking mushrooms
that a lot of my [ __ ] that seemed like
it was a mountain i would say this in my
podcast you think you got to climb up a
mountain it's just stepping up on a curb
right it's just this you're just stuck
in like this
sort of muscle memory thing and uh
so um
i don't know there's just oh my god dude
like i got to watch it again and like
if i'm giving away too much let me know
but i also loved
like the wardrobe
oh it's just spot-on like it's just all
like boston is just so many like just
local sports teams and then older people
wearing t-shirts they think are funny
right well it makes me happy you're
saying this because that was a big part
when we were writing is i kept saying
like we have to make sure it seems fun
because otherwise why would this guy go
and get abused because that's the thing
about family
is it is confu it's really really fun
until it's not and the same with the
outfits is like we had this guy michael
who was great uh he was the wardrobe guy
and we worked together
trying to find all that stuff that was
kind of old sweatshirts and we want it
to look like the kind of house which is
real in my family like there's just
sweatshirts that live at the house yeah
where it gets chilly in maine in the
summer and you just grab sweatshirts out
of a [ __ ] wooden box yeah and then it
becomes like these old like ad campaigns
that you have still the spuds mckenzie
[ __ ]
t-shirt but like um
oh what was i just gonna say there was
like uh
just so many moments in that movie that
i i
i really really
related to once again dude i just think
you did such a phenomenal job with like
the acting lady
and i saw it in the first scene i was
like when you're doing like the phone
calls like this [ __ ] guy can act man
you know because i don't i never seen
you in anything so i was like oh no i've
never done it this might be a rough one
maybe convince some of your friends in
the movie business to do the same
dude i'm barely in
i'm barely in dude that's and i'll tell
you that's how most people are out here
it's like you're never really
you're never really in which is always
fascinates me when people uh
are [ __ ] and it's just like dude it
is so hard to get in like how long do
you think you're gonna stay in like i
think back in the day you could be an
[ __ ] right because there was so much
work and now this seems like there's a
lot of work but not as much money
but like
i also think because now that they
opened it up
where now there's so much talent i was
compared to like jackie robinson like
before jackie robinson came into the
baseball league there was a lot of white
guys that shouldn't have been there
right and the first white dude that got
replaced was whoever [ __ ] was playing
shortstop for the brooklyn dodgers but
now that they've sort of they've blown
it out and they're actually letting so
many more people show what they can do
you're getting the de niros and the
kytels of every race every gender and
all of that type of [ __ ] there's so much
great [ __ ] out there and there's so many
great actors that now
you're it's not this small pool where
you can just
you know get into your ego and be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's just like well all
right well i'll go get the [ __ ]
korean version of you and that dude will
crush it and no one will give a [ __ ]
that it's not some [ __ ] white guy
playing it and then that person's gonna
crush it and then you're back out on the
curb
and you'd be
surprised uh
the people that don't get that that
don't get it was just like dude like
people really don't have to work with
[ __ ] anymore well that's the also
with acting like aud i mean i
got this
role because we wrote it and
he was like you'll play this but
every i don't go on a lot of auditions
i've never done that much but it's like
every audition i've ever got to like i
do the audition i'm like don't pick me
right obviously that was terrible that's
a good vibe anything i've ever
auditioned for i watch and i'm like yeah
yeah that was way better than i would
it's it's crazy to think like oh i'm the
best for this role
but you have to have it i guess uh
i would say
what you do is you [ __ ] just any
audition you have you just go in have
fun
kill it and be cool
like you're going to be on set and
you're not going to be a [ __ ] problem
right because sometimes
you know they'll pick you over someone
who was better but gave off like they're
gonna be a [ __ ] headache right so you
just show up on time in shape knowing
your [ __ ] lines ready to work and
when they're breaking down
to do like another camera angle just get
the [ __ ] out of the way right and then
when when somebody comes by and says hey
you know five minutes or whatever just
be like right there
ready to go in and i'm telling you after
like three days the director always
comes up like i never have to wait for
you and like dude that will get you more
[ __ ] work than actually being good
that's always been my approach with
stand up i felt that was stand up from
an early spot of like all right i got to
be like super pro
because you know
i have to be the pro so i'm like i've
never gone over in my life i'm like i'll
be there a half hour early i won't walk
anybody if somebody heckles i'll be like
can we please do something i don't want
to be the guy that's like oh you know
i'll beat the [ __ ] out of you you
[ __ ] count whatever
so i've always felt that way of like
i'll be on time i'll stick to my time i
won't bother anybody i promise do you
know uh
i feel
as far as clock management now obviously
i didn't start anywhere else i don't
think any place was as rigid
as boston when i was like coming up like
it would literally be like uh
hey pal that'd be mike clark
you know he's supposed to do 20. you
know you did 21 and a half
let's try to keep it tighter on the next
show well you know
noxie doesn't want to be waiting around
all night and it was just
well boston also was literally this is
so insane to me the last city in america
to adopt the light system for those like
every comedy club has a light we give
you a light when there's two minutes
left there's a light in the background
boston the whole time i lived there from
2000 to 2007 they never did it and
everyone would say with attitude like
you keep track of your own [ __ ] time
yeah and then if you look at your watch
they're like what are you looking at
your watch and i'm like i don't
understand why i feel 20. yeah i'm like
i don't know i have to work on my own
here i have to just like
judge it like a like a farmer or
whatever it's my second farmer reference
i remember i used to have like those
cheapo like uh digital watches yes and i
would set it
and they ladies and gentlemen you know
new guy plays clubs in colleges up and
down the east coast when he had no
credits that's what they said up and
down the east coast which meant you were
just doing [ __ ] chinese restaurants
and bar rooms in the local area and
right as they brought me up i would go
beep like that
and i probably would check my watch like
27 times in a 20-minute set to make sure
i wasn't going over and then it was like
literally like i would get nervous if i
did 19 minutes 53 seconds yeah that they
because if you went under hey you did
short time you did 18. you're supposed
to do 20. it's just like well i didn't
want to get into the next bit because
it's a three-minute bit and then i get
my balls broken if i if i uh if i go
over like it was like a big and if a
headliner
you went over once yes like you were
like put on [ __ ]
like notice no scary and then two
weekends in a row or if the right
headliner bitched about you which i saw
happen
um just because he didn't like this
guy's act
he was like a music guy yeah and he used
to do this like he would start and off
by doing like all like uh he was into
silence like how long he could go
without saying anything and get laughs
and he had like this weird face and sort
of turn around and make
so
and it was funny they were killed but
the headliner was one of these people
like you know jokes are said with the
mouth using words right not using your
face and i'm thinking like well he is
killing so that like
the dude worked friday two shows and was
just not there
on the saturday and i remember that put
the [ __ ] fear of god in me like oh my
god this [ __ ] thor the guy headlining
is just throwing lightning bolts down at
people in front of him just uh
eviscerating him and i was like really
uh
yeah that's right when i started out
that's why i worked clean when i started
out because i didn't want to piss off
any headliners same yeah
maybe that's why it related to your
movie fourth of july once again yes
louis ck.com yeah or you can go to 4th
of julymovie.com will take you directly
there if you if you're not good at
navigating a website
some people go to the louie's website
and they're like i can't find it and
you're like just i don't know [ __ ] it
it's on there but you can go to 4th of
julymovie.com it takes you directly to
the the part of his page where you can
buy that made me feel good because i
went to his website and i was able to
figure it out i usually
can't figure anything out all right
let's promote some dates here uh oh uh i
didn't even get a chance to talk uh red
sox with you one of the things i want to
do at some point i want to go to a sox
game with you i'd love to because you
give a [ __ ] about it i love the way i do
um we text each other occasionally
during the uh
regular season like he's he's the only
guy i know i can hit up on like [ __ ]
game
72 and he's just like i know right what
the [ __ ]
why did they why didn't they pull that
guy
no i love it i love it i was just saying
off the u.s open i can't concentrate on
two sports at once so when the u.s opens
going on my baseball really goes down
the [ __ ] for two weeks but
um i i've been to
three of the four tennis majors i just
need wimbledon i've been to two i've
been i haven't been to australia i've
been to french in u.s i go to every year
yeah i got to go to wimbledon dude maybe
i'll do wimbledon next year you come out
you open for me we'll [ __ ] go oh i'd
love that that'd be sick to go to
breakfast at wimbledon remember that
growing up with dick enberg i would love
that um i'm a big tennis i went to the
australian one just
by accident i [ __ ] was just happy to
play in melbourne and i came walking in
and there was this giant tennis ball
and it said australian open and i was
just like wait a second is that here
right now they're like yeah like can we
buy tickets they go yeah through the
hotel
and like
we had a day off and we just went over
and uh we saw uh we saw serena play nice
and i just remember there was some some
australian girl
whatever her name was like australians
are big on like nicknames
so uh i just remember this guy in the
crowd just kept going come on casey
come on casey the whole [ __ ] time if
people go like trying to shush him and
[ __ ]
um i'm speaking real quick speaking of
uh the socks in australia i pay every
day every year patriots day i go to the
sox game i go to the marathon
i was in high school i didn't go to the
game but i went to the marathon i was at
the finish line and whoever the
wheelchair lady i don't even know what
year this was 90 something the
wheelchair lady must have been australia
and someone won and they were doing the
australian national anthem everyone's
trying to sit in there being as
respectful as possible and then you just
hear a guy go up socks one and everyone
goes
[Applause]
he must have been listening on the radio
or got you know whatever
someone uh it couldn't have been a text
it must have been the radio he just
announced that the sox won the
australian anthem it's just that's one
of my favorite things i miss most about
that is there's just so many funny
[ __ ] hilarious they don't even know
how funny they are and everybody's just
like yeah that totally makes sense you
know what i mean he wouldn't yell at him
he'd probably say it during the national
anthem too so let's uh let's promote
some dates where can we see
the great
prolific thank you joe list thank you um
i don't even know i don't know when this
comes out but um
comedianjoelist.com all my dates are on
there i don't know promote some towards
the end of the year dude i'm telling you
i i
i approve of this message this guy's a
[ __ ] beast man thank you i'm at i
know i'm at i don't know my dates off
the top of my head i'm an idiot i should
have this is why i'm bad at the business
this is why i can't sell out all right
i'm at uh comedy on state in december in
madison which is my favorite club i got
hartford funny bone coming up syracuse
funny bone um i got a big date in april
patriots day weekend i'm gonna be at the
wilbur theater which is my first year
which is very exciting i think it's
april 15th and um
you can be the next big uh boston guy i
think i hope so thank you it's
comedianjoelist.com and you can see both
my specials on youtube i hate myself and
this year's material they're free for
god's sakes watch them you have no
reason exactly and he's a beast of a
comedian and he's starring
and and wrote a co-wrote with louis ck
uh just such a just a beautiful movie
dude fourth of july five stars from old
freckles joe thank you so much for
swinging by the uh podcast and continued
success and uh you know i look forward
to more films [ __ ] you and i can play an
[ __ ] uncle you know yeah i would love
myself yeah please yeah i'll play i'll
play a cuck nerd in whatever you're
working on anything you need before all
right beautiful all right joe list
everybody uh
please enjoy the music uh picked out by
uh the wonderful andrew themeless and
we'll have a bonus episode of the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast right after the
music
and that's it have a great weekend you
can't
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
september 22nd 2014. how you doing how
are you
did you enjoy your weekend
well that's good i had to wait till you
responded you see that that's the new me
trying to be a little more courteous
trying
to listen to the listener
no to the speaker
that's how much i i interrupt people i
actually call
the other person talking the listener
this i call the speaker the listener
that's how i do it
now gives a [ __ ] um
anyways i got another goddamn busy week
i uh been writing
on this show
that i'm trying to get on the [ __ ]
air and i'm not going to tell you really
what it is because it doesn't make a
difference because most of them don't
end up making it so
but i've been in the bubble doing that
all [ __ ] day and then at night i'm
trying to go out and write some new
jokes because i got some shows coming up
um i'm gonna be in uh san francisco we
just added another show
at the davies arena whatever the [ __ ]
it's called
and uh so i appreciate everybody in san
francisco
i plan on kicking the [ __ ] out of you
and giving you your money's worth so
i've been going out like every night
here in los angeles trying to get up on
stage somewhere
somehow somewhere
and uh i've been writing during the day
i got a [ __ ] job everybody
you know i got a little passcode key i
come in say hello to the [ __ ]
person at the desk how are you
and i [ __ ] do the little swipey thing
and i go in there
and i [ __ ] go in there and i
try to come up with some funny [ __ ] to
add to the other funny [ __ ] that other
people are writing
um no
jesus
it's actually been a lot of fun to be
honest with you and uh i'm learning i'm
learning to write i'm learning how a
script comes together which i never knew
how to do it because i was too
scatterbrained
and uh for the most part
in life i'm a [ __ ] quitter
i really am i just when i go to do
something if it's easy and it's fun i
keep doing it if there's a little bit of
work to it
that brutal combination is if there's a
little bit of work and i don't like it
i'm done
and uh that would explain my my high
school transcript
i did horrible
[ __ ]
horrible in high school
mike i don't know how like if that was a
pga tournament i would not have made the
cut
um
i think freshman year i might have made
the cut but sophomore no junior no and
especially not senior year it was it was
over
it was [ __ ] over you know what you
know what my [ __ ] high school
performance was like
basically the broncos
in last year's super bowl
all right i walked up to the line of
scrimmage and i'm like i'm going to be a
lawyer i'm going to notre dame that's
what i'm doing freshman year right here
comes you know first play from scrimmage
oh
everybody yelling
and it [ __ ] went right up over my
head for a safety
i never got the rhythm back i know there
was no rhythm
there was nothing i did really well i
did really well right up to eighth grade
not really really well but i did great i
gradually tapered off
my like my academic career from first
grade
to 12th grade was like like an athlete's
career
you know i had young fresh legs and
everything was going great i was
bouncing up after hits and tackles and
all that [ __ ] i cruised through first
second and third grade
then i got my first
c i think in fourth grade
then in fifth grade
i had to quit my baseball team because i
got a d in math then sixth grade i came
back strong
contract year right going into seventh
grade
seventh grade i did decent eighth grade
i did decent didn't quite live up to the
big contract they gave me after that
stunning sixth grade year
and then ninth grade oh i don't know i
blew out my achilles
came back from injury and the sophomore
just i just [ __ ] the bed it was over
it was over
by senior year i was wearing my joe
namath rams jersey academically speaking
and it was [ __ ] over
and that's the way it was back in 1987.
um so anyways this is the monday morning
podcast uh any new listings listeners
out there how are you welcome to people
who listen to this around the world
world world world world
um what the [ __ ] happened in scotland
you know you would have you i thought
that they were gonna break away
i thought they had had enough you know
what i should do is i shouldn't read up
on it at all i should just start talking
about it you know
that's my god-given right as a [ __ ]
american right scotland
um independence
let's see what happened
well the folks are [ __ ] caught the
podcast you're [ __ ] scared wearing
[ __ ]
um
polls were pretty bad it says scotland
faces challenge of putting reference
referendum behind them oh yeah you just
stirred everybody up
there's probably even more fights in the
buzz
i can't do a scottish accent the only
reason i could say what i already said
was because it was said to me other than
that i can't do it i'm like a really bad
person here you know what i mean like
if i if those like a really bad
impressionist all they do is the [ __ ]
that people say in the movies like i'll
be back they just do that but you know
the really great ones like jaymore can
actually do uh arnold schwarzenegger in
therapy talking about having a child out
of wedlock
you know
um anyways
well i'm all over the [ __ ] place
the pros and cons of scottish
independence
as if your life wasn't boring enough
let's talk about this [ __ ]
i think it's a good move that they
didn't uh
that they didn't break away
right
does scotland have an army or a navy
go [ __ ] yourselves all right i'm sorry
that i don't know this [ __ ] okay
why don't you [ __ ] invade somebody
every once in a while and maybe maybe
i'll know about your teams over there
all right the effort the referendum ends
one debate but sparks a new question
about the
devolution of power to scotland i hope i
said that right scotland has rejected
independence following a historically
high turnout at yesterday's referendum
chief counting officer mary piccadilly
whatever the [ __ ] her name is has
officially announced that no side won by
55 percent
although no side
i'm the worst
that the no side won by 55
percent to 45 percent no normal person
was allowed to count the votes so
everyone has to take that as fact
uh the clerk and my
shire council was the first local
authority to announce its results at
around 1 30 a.m who gives a [ __ ] union
is celebrated victories blah blah blah
blah nationalist one dundee by pretty
blah blah blah
well what the [ __ ] wait a minute wait
wait wait wait
when did scotland become part of the uk
the acts of union between scotland and
england were passed in 1706 taking
effect didn't they get taken over
i don't know
something happened there next thing you
know mel gibson was in dress that's all
i know
he was in a skirt
um
yeah why you gonna well you know i don't
you know something i don't know anything
about it
i don't know anything about it but i bet
there was a bunch of old scottish people
who didn't want to upset
you know they were going to take the
evil that they knew rather than the
unknown evil
you know what are they doing taxing the
[ __ ] out of you making you do the [ __ ]
jobs
is that what it is what would have
happened to england if scott can you
guys answer me these [ __ ] questions
because i'm not going to read up on it
what would have happened to the power of
england
you know
which i don't even know what it's based
on at this point because they don't own
[ __ ] anymore do they
what do they own
they got like the canary islands in
northern ireland
in scotland and wales
right
falkland islands didn't they lose that
something happened over there like 30
[ __ ] years ago and all of a sudden
the planes were taken off straight
straight up in the air
remember that
way back in the day nancy reagan ronald
reagan
uh
margaret thatcher
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know what
happened i can't believe how little i
even know about it i can even i i i
don't know anything about it i'm gonna
shut up then
well congratulations to people of
scotland uh who didn't want to leave and
i feel bad for those who did
and i really wish i could have talked
about it a little more intelligently but
you know every once in a while you just
you just you know you think the water's
like two inches deep and next thing you
know you're in over your head that's
what happened to me oh jesus that might
have been the worst discussion of
anything political ever that was even
bad for me that was a [ __ ]
embarrassment i'll tell you right now if
uh that last conversation was indicative
of what this podcast is going to be i
can tell you right now i don't think
he's going to get it done this week
okay and if you think that you're going
to have a good podcast in the national
podcasting league with that type of
performance uh i mean what does that say
about preparation
make a change
um
i didn't watch any of that you guys
watching the pre-game analysis you know
what i was i i have a rental car of
course still a rental car i haven't seen
my [ __ ] truck in like months
because the uh people fixing the
downstairs they got to walk through my
garage and i don't want to get it
scratched i don't leave it out on the
street so i got it in storage i started
up once a week that's my life
okay
so anyways i've been driving this
[ __ ] car i got this new one and i
suck with technology i can't figure out
how to turn the radio on to auxiliary so
i can listen to my [ __ ] show tunes
there
as i drive down the street street right
roll out the barrel
it's the kind of music i listen to when
i drive
you know
i listen to funny girl
oklahoma when there's something
something in this something right
i don't know any [ __ ] show tunes wait
a minute to dream the impossible dream
to dress like a [ __ ] kitty cat
to descend on a glowing moon
while a crowd of old hags and some young
homosexuals
cry in the crowd
um anyways
all right what the [ __ ] am i talking
about here
there was something i wanted to talk
about before i started singing show
tunes oh yeah i was driving down the
[ __ ] street in the car and i can't
figure out how to listen to my my
goddamn songs so i've just been
listening to sports talk radio because i
don't want to listen to
real news
it's too [ __ ] depressing
i don't want to listen to them try and
sell me on the idea that we just have to
go into syria
you know we just gotta do it
it's our job
to go over there
and tell these people hey hey hey that's
about enough for that
as we suck their natural resources out
of the [ __ ] ground and bomb the
living [ __ ] out of innocent people
standing around you know i don't want to
listen to them sell me in on another one
of those
well it's an issue of freedom the way
they are
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care anymore
all right
oh and i would vote i would vote if you
actually [ __ ] counted them
um and if i wasn't lazy as [ __ ] i got a
big pamphlet today that was telling me
all about the local officials and i just
took one look at that just it's written
on recycled paper
it's overcast paper that's what it looks
like overcast skies except there's
typing on it they do it on purpose
who the [ __ ] is gonna read that
um
so anyways i was driving down the street
and i'm listening to uh that mike and
mike in the morning and like i've been
i've been really hard on these [ __ ]
pregame post-game sports talk guys i
actually now have empathy for them i
understand what they're doing
there's just too much time
there's too much air time between games
and they just have to talk everything
to death
and this week
i swear to god
mike golick of the mike and mike show
right
they read a letter
and uh it was somebody who's basically
he was taught he was respectfully tired
of listening to
the adrian peterson story the ray rice
story and all of that [ __ ]
and was just like can we just get back
to talking about football signed a tired
football fan and i swear to god this i'm
paraphrasing but this is kind of what
golic said he goes you know what i want
to do i want to
i want to right now
i don't want to talk to the players
i don't want to talk to the owners i
want to talk to the media i want to talk
to you
the fan
they know mike mike this is something
that i want to get out there is
is this game
your safe haven
is it your safe haven
like
on sunday
when you sit down in your chair
and and and
and and you you you take out your your
your favorite beverage
is that your safe haven
is the national football he kept saying
is that your safe haven what the [ __ ]
does that mean
how simplistic and [ __ ] stupid do
they think the average football fan is
was i supposed to be driving in my car
going yeah it is my safe haven
i feel anything of safety when i watch
football
what the [ __ ] is he talking about i
gotta tell you something this is really
immature me i hate when overweight
people bring up food i don't know what
it is but i swear to god you can already
hear them salivating
i never had an issue with the word
beverage until i heard mike golick say
it and you take out your favorite
beverage
i just heard the [ __ ] ice hitting the
inside of the glass and i swear to god i
wanted to drive into a [ __ ] pole i
had to shut it off like three times but
i was like no this is good for the
podcast
you got to listen to it
and uh he just is it is it your safe
haven
i mean just absolutely out of [ __ ] to
talk about i mean i don't know what i
didn't what what the what the [ __ ] does
that i didn't listen to it long enough
did somebody actually call in
a safe [ __ ] haven
you know what i'm gonna look that up
right now and i want to see examples of
safe havens i know exactly what they are
it's like captains in the middle of a
[ __ ] storm trying to find a porch so
they don't get smashed on rocks yeah
either that or some fat [ __ ] in his
pajamas
with some potato skins watching football
yeah just let's just let's just [ __ ]
devalue safe haven
i'm looking it up right now
well it was a movie
there's a film
it's a county how about a [ __ ]
definition
well bill why don't you search for that
and stop yelling at a screen all right
all right definition
safe haven a place of refuge or security
temporary refuge given to a person
persecuted person or group so is he
trying to say that we're persecuted by
them saying talking about the same [ __ ]
day after [ __ ] day after day
is it your safe haven
an officially protected place in an area
of military activity or any safe or
peaceful place in a dangerous area
all right i mean nuts to say that he
overstepped the bounds
of the definition of that word
to apply it to sitting there [ __ ]
eating pizza and drinking booze
you know
i don't [ __ ] know
anyways
um and i'm sitting there going like how
[ __ ] dumb does this guy think
the average football fan is and then i
watch the fsu game
and i am a huge fan
of florida state
i've always loved the seminoles i want
to go to a game i went to i did a
showdown there like a year and a half
ago but i got to tell you something i
watched this [ __ ] game
and in the first drive alone they played
that [ __ ]
what do you call the tomahawk chant song
they must have played it like seven
times
[Music]
right and the [ __ ] crowd is going
like
[Music]
[ __ ] arms
i get it everybody's got their little
thing that they do
you know
and uh you know i you know whatever you
just kind of [ __ ] mocking mocking a a
group of people that
were victims of genocide
i mean who's to say i mean if the nazis
you know if they they won world war ii
or would they not have had their version
of the tomahawk chop with uh
jewish people
what would they be doing what is what if
you were doing if the nazis won and then
they [ __ ] named their team offensive
names
about jewish people what would the
tomahawk
chop what would it be
or whatever the [ __ ] you was
oh [ __ ] you i'm sorry what do you want
from me i'm tired right they would all
have like [ __ ]
they'd be dressed like acidic jews or
something like that but cartoonish
versions like one of them would come out
riding a [ __ ] horse with a goddamn
briefcase or some
[ __ ] and he'd [ __ ] go to slam it down
in the 50-yard line forgetting it was
handcuffed to his wrist and he turned
his head into a lawn dart something like
that right
the berlin woody allens
berlin woodys
um sorry what do you want from me um
anyways
anyways what the [ __ ] so i they and then
what was worse was they kept cutting to
the crowd
and you know i thought the i heard
nothing you know
i always heard that the chicks at fsu
were [ __ ]
i heard they were hot dude all i saw it
looked like you know
there was a hurricane
and everybody
i don't know
they looked for a safe haven in [ __ ]
walmart and they just opened the door
and all these [ __ ] zombies came out
just a bunch of people standing there
mindlessly moving their [ __ ] arm
like i'm telling you like 15 20 times a
half
40 times in a [ __ ] game you're
sitting there doing that [ __ ] and i just
i'm you know what i want to do right now
i don't want to talk to the players
i don't want to talk to me i want to
talk to the fans i want to talk to the
fans
in that [ __ ] stadium like what what
is going through your [ __ ] head
the 30th the 35th [ __ ] time you're
doing that at any point do you sit there
and start to question whether you're an
individual anymore
what kind of a [ __ ] person do you i
fear i don't know i never been to the
game do you take a few of them off
right now you know what i'm not gonna do
it this time just so i can keep a piece
of me
right i don't don't listen to me i am
completely
i am anti-social
like beyond belief and the stuff that
actually makes me mad
it's weird i like can't stand people and
i also like them
i can't stand them to the point i don't
want to be around them but when i see
them doing [ __ ] that i feel they're
above
um it makes me sad for them like i was
sad for some of those people when i
looked at him like what are you doing
come on you know
i don't want to use that hacky term
you're better than that i hate when
people say that [ __ ] you're better than
that it's like you know what you're
better you're better than you're better
than that all right don't try your
[ __ ] first grade psychology on me
don't worry baby i am better than that
oh i guess i agree with you now give me
a [ __ ] break
um
it's like when you see people waiting
out for a [ __ ]
phone
like those [ __ ] losers i get it
you're into that i get it that you're
into it
all right
whatever the [ __ ] i'm into
all right
whatever i like playing drums let's say
they came out with the greatest [ __ ]
drum kit you could have a [ __ ] hat
and i wanted it
worse than i and i wanted anything in my
life like the way those [ __ ] kids
like the goddamn iphone this i'm not
sleeping out on a sidewalk for it
when a week later i could just walk in
like a [ __ ] human being go yeah let
me get one of those thank you
box it up they're rusty right
gotta be the first one
okay the first one has the phone
you know i asked this week on twitter i
asked what what roku was
somebody gave me a roku right
i had no idea what i opened it
and uh i had no idea what it was
and
um
you know what's funny i i so didn't even
know what it was i don't even like read
i noticed that by myself like it said
roku right on the box
but i was just looking at the picture of
it and i was reading the fine print
immediately and i didn't know what the
[ __ ] it was so i did a live podcast with
al madrigal
and uh i was trying to describe what it
was because i didn't know what it was
and neil brennan i got to give him props
actually called it he said is it a roku
and i think i said no
anyways
i tried looking it up on the internet
and in the description of it i still
didn't understand what it was so like an
[ __ ] i asked on my twitter i go hey
does any any i just said you know what
what's a roku
and you can't believe this [ __ ] i
understand like the funny answers that
people gave me but there was a lot of
people giving me [ __ ] [ __ ] like i was
a [ __ ] or something
i don't get that [ __ ] talking with
technology where just because you go out
and you buy the latest thing like that
somehow makes you smarter than me now
it's not i could see if you invented it
like the person who invented roku said i
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean i gotta take
that one on the chin
but if you're just another
mouth-breathing [ __ ] like me walking
around a [ __ ] best buy
and you walk in and you buy a roku i
mean i don't i don't get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] talk that's all i'm saying all
these nerds all of a sudden acting like
cornerbacks in the nfl
getting in my [ __ ] face on twitter
jesus i feel like i'm bitching a lot
this week let's let's do a little uh
let's do a little advertisement
let's do a little advertisement here um
all right
all right with that let's get back to
the uh to the podcast here um
anyways what else did i do this week i
watched a bunch of football i got to
tell you um
i got to tell you i got to be a little
concerned with what i saw up there in
foxborough with the new england patriots
um
i don't know you know what the patriots
have been doing forever is we we get rid
of guys
we get rid of veterans
in the final third of their career when
they want the big bucks we kind of let
them go tai law lawyer malloy
uh that [ __ ] defensive tackle we sent
to the raiders i mean there's been so
many of them
latest one
logan mankins sent him to uh tampa bay
or whatever
and um i don't think that's working for
us
because you get a great veteran and then
that dude leaves
and then you have a hole in that
position for like three years waiting
for somebody to get up to speed and by
the time that guy figures out how to
play the position somebody else gets let
go and now we got a problem over there i
mean i guess you're always gonna have a
[ __ ] problem
but um
i don't know i see a slowly starting to
slide
i mean the way we let
the raiders hang around that long and
they should have won the [ __ ] game
they didn't shoot now the raiders they
didn't shoot themselves in the foot
i just don't understand why the raiders
they just i don't know it's like they
they knew how to win games and for the
last 30 years they stopped
all went out the [ __ ] i don't know i
think it's karma
it's a karma thing it has to do with
their fans and how they disgrace being a
football fan by going there
dressed up like spongebob squarepants
but you have on brass knuckles i just
don't understand that i don't understand
why you have to take your dignity and
throw it out the [ __ ] window i'm not
talking about all raider fans i'm
talking you know what fans i'm talking
about
alright so thank god
it was a home game so they didn't have
to keep talking about the black hole
you know
you know there's you know those places
the black hole the dog pound
the entire seattle seahawks stadium
actually watched it what a [ __ ] game
that was man
um seattle uh broncos game [ __ ]
awesome game but at one point they cut
to the crowd and some guy had this
[ __ ]
lime green sound that sign that just
said loud
like he went out and made that or
something
it's just the dumbest thing
um i have to commend him i i mean i fast
forward through a lot of it because i
you know i
was out living a life and i came back
and i watched the tape my tape of the uh
the game and uh they didn't bring it up
that much which thank god they didn't
enough already with the stupid 12th man
and all of that [ __ ]
um
anyways but the game
was [ __ ] awesome and um
i thought seattle i thought it was done
and uh what was it 20 to 5 17 to 5 or
something like that i think it was like
21.5 i don't even know and [ __ ]
broncos came back
you know peyton throws the big pick and
then comes back with the i don't know i
don't get why on that final drive
whenev it's every [ __ ] drive is that
the prevent defense they always go down
the field and score or they always they
always drive down at the very least
they're gonna get in the red zone
that whole [ __ ] of like you know
we'll uh take away the sidelines and
we'll give them the middle of the field
and somehow there's just magically not
supposed to be enough time left on the
clock and there [ __ ] always is like
90 of the time
but it actually seemed like uh
seattle was playing defense is that you
blowing your nose in there nia
now she's got the allergies
um
such a cute little nose she makes all
that noise um
anyways it was a great [ __ ] game and
i was happy that uh
you know both teams played well and
there wasn't any [ __ ] incidents of
screaming and yelling or any of that
type of [ __ ]
um the day started off bad with them
talking about the uh
the goddamn
paul tagging boo or [ __ ] pete rozelle
whatever the [ __ ] new guy's name is i
don't even know what his name is
doug fairbanks we're gonna go with that
gary greenberg what the [ __ ] is his name
you think that's how much i don't watch
it i put it on and there's tom jackson
and uh keenan ivory wayans or whatever
the [ __ ] keyshawn johnson right
and i'm like i like those guys those
guys used to play they know the [ __ ]
game and then you know
they got the big
pasty doughy boy it looks like he's in
one of those bigfoot [ __ ] sitcoms
right
third rock from the sun where they lived
with bigfoot and alf made like a cameo
whatever the hell one of those furry
[ __ ] shows right
he looks like the dad on one of those
shows doesn't he and um
like if he was a chick he'd be like a
milk maiden you know
but he'd only be like a six
so anyways he goes up there
and he's like you know i didn't get
right a lot of stuff uh i could have got
right i didn't get it right next time uh
we're gonna do everything to make sure
we get it right
get it right
he's in there and sports speak
and then they cut back to the players
and then the players you know who are
now [ __ ] wearing anderson little
suits and they're [ __ ] then they
start talking going like uh you know i
heard an apology but uh
i didn't hear any they didn't hear
anything that was saying what are they
gonna do in the future oh my god
is it wrong to say who gives a [ __ ] at
this point
the guy's not gonna quit his goddamn job
you're not gonna kick him out
all right he gets it
next time a player slugs his wife fiance
or just some random woman
walking down the street in in the face
they're gonna show the whole video
the first day
and they will suspend the person
indefinitely
okay
you know it's great halfway through when
i was listening to that sports talk
radio show they had al michael's calling
who does not speak in sport speak
because uh you know
he's found his own voice he's a legend
so he called up and he was just saying
how the whole league got tired and
feathered because of a couple of guys
and he actually claimed
that
the spousal abuse rate
in the nfl
not only is less than general society
but way less
so
what was all the screaming and yelling
about
i don't [ __ ] get it all that [ __ ]
they have a real problem they actually
look like they're doing a little better
doing better than the plumbers
contractors stand-up comedians and
everybody else walking around outside
that stadium
the new drinking game
listen to mike and mike in the morning
and every time
mike golick goes and in between points
you got to take a shot i swear to god
you're going to have your stomach pumped
45 minutes into it
they came out in the first quarter and i
mean they were all over them
um
okay
is there anything else to talk about
here i talked about roku i talked about
the games that i watched
um oh double bass drumming by the way
i'm trying to you know i made fun of i
didn't make fun of it i just said you
know it's just so [ __ ] fast after a
while that i i
you know i don't hear a groove anymore
and some double bass drummers called uh
called me up they [ __ ] twittered me
and they were like ah kind of bummed me
out you said you didn't like the blast
beats and [ __ ] like that i i don't mean
i don't like them i just
you know my i don't know i just don't
gravitate towards uh i already have that
level of rage in me i don't need a
soundtrack to it like i i need to go the
other way i need to listen to the sounds
of waterfalls
you know um
so anyways
i want to do another one of those uh
goddamn comedy jams and the song that i
picked out had a little bit of double
bass in it so i've been trying to get
you know i pulled out the double pedal
from the [ __ ] back of the closet
and
um i gotta tell you man it [ __ ] it's
it's hard as [ __ ]
i've always respected that's why um i
bought it like i bought a double pedal
like 12 years ago when my obsession with
john bonham got to the point that all i
was doing was listening to led zeppelin
and i wasn't developing at all
any creative ideas nothing playing drums
so i was like why don't i get outside of
this and get a double pedal and i [ __ ]
around with it on and off and i just
never
had the discipline
to stay with it so i've been trying to
stay with it the last couple of weeks
and um
i'm [ __ ] horrible
i'm horrible i mean i'm talking like 85
90 beats per minute before it starts
sounding like i'm galloping
rather than a nice smooth sound so uh i
got i always had a ton of respect um oh
you know what's funny i actually opened
for uh i went down and did a guest spot
in front of uh dean del rey at the
improv this week
and uh he used to sing in a band so he
knows all these uh
musicians and one of the guys that came
down out to the show was the drummer
from slayer uh dave lombardo i got to
talk to him for a couple seconds
speaking of you know
legendary drum double bass drumming
um
was a great [ __ ] guy and um i don't
know it's one of the great things about
living out here in la
is like you'll [ __ ] move somewhere
and that guy will be your next door
neighbor
because there's just people are in show
business out here it's [ __ ] hilarious
you know i went to a super bowl party
one time and i met somebody and they
were just like yeah
they started talking to him and i found
out his his grandfather
played the guy that was in the bed
with the severed horse head
and godfather one
how [ __ ] cool is that
it's like your grandfather did that yeah
yeah you know he had no idea how big the
movie was gonna be they put a fake head
in there and he uh he screamed and
yelled
what did your grandfather do he worked
at avis
um all right
let's move on okay let's get to the
letters for this week
the [ __ ]
lettuce
uh bill stop saying sorry dear billy
redface i've i have been listening to
your podcast for about a year and you
are hilarious
and i have noticed he's spelling with
like letters
not and he just the letter n and i have
noticed you say something outrageous
and funny then say sorry
you're not responsible you can say
whatever the [ __ ] you want
two ends in one
without
apologizing
both of those words spelled wrong keep
that [ __ ] up you funny bastard thanks
for the podcast and go [ __ ] yourself
um
no i'm gonna keep saying sorry if i
[ __ ] do a joke i think it's a little
corny or uh i went a little too long
with it i apologize i'm trying to have
respect for you
but i appreciate the fact that you
enjoyed the podcast please keep
listening all right american who grew up
in singapore oh i love it last week did
any of you guys have the nerve to go
look at that caning video holy [ __ ]
that's not something you don't look at
it because you won't ever forget it
um hey billy i have i have lived so this
is an american who grew up in singapore
i've lived in singapore for five years
or i lived in singapore for five years
in the late 80s through the early 90s i
was a kid but i remember they had public
commercials for caning
some were like the semi-funny dui
commercials we have in california and
some were like short film versions of
hot of hostiles oh of hostile
oh wasn't that a horror movie
they even had billboards and bus signs
that depicted offenses that would warn
it warrant caning complete with
sore assed cartoon characters caning was
even a thing in their soap operas and tv
shows
the message was clear you [ __ ] around
and you're gonna get caned
the michael fay thing happened when i
was 11. this is fascinating but i
remember feeling no sympathy for the guy
i always thought he gave the u.s a bad
name for a being a dumbass in a foreign
country and b
not owning up to his own [ __ ] i have
no love for singapore but i think their
nation points out a sad fact
the only way you can have a society with
less than one murder a year no drug
offenders with a pristine subway
and then he writes in
parentheses you could literally eat ice
cream off the floor is by hanging felons
and beating the [ __ ] out of everyone
else
love you
[Laughter]
oh my god
jesus christ is that true
can you imagine if they had caning in
this country how many how many of us
would deserve a caning
how [ __ ] crash you can act and that
and that before you get on your [ __ ]
high horse anybody listen to this in
canada england and australia and all the
other goddamn places okay you'd all take
a couple of [ __ ] you take a nice
couple of [ __ ] whacks yourself
you know
i went to slap my leg and even then i
pulled it because i didn't pull the
punch because i didn't want to [ __ ]
hurt myself um
yeah i guess so if you hang felons
that really cuts out the whole uh
recidivism
you know no no repeat offenders in
singapore
then they beat the and let me tell you
something they beat the [ __ ] out of you
this guy took like six of them
like that sometimes like i heard
punishments of up to 12 and some people
were saying like other parts of the
world you get like 96 lashings
i mean you just passed out
i gotta tell you is inhumane as it is
like let's just say i got i you know i
don't want to put this [ __ ] id in
anybody's head
i have jesus christ
how many fi i mean that would be it i
would i would
i don't know what i would do
you know what i would do i would i would
work in the back of a cold stone
creamery if i ever took 96 lashings that
would be it that'd be the end of my
dreams all of that would be a broken man
like all right dude i get it you're
running [ __ ]
[ __ ] this i'm going in the back here i'm
going to [ __ ] stir up some ice cream
i'll come out when i gotta sing the hi
ho hi ho we're making ice cream we go
whatever [ __ ] song i gotta sing
i'm wearing the uniform
you know
everybody likes to think that there'd be
that guy going you know after they're
giving you 96 lashes and you're sitting
there
you know when they come up to you and
they say something then you go [ __ ] you
and you spit in their face
i think that just happens in the movies
even if you're thinking [ __ ] you you're
not gonna say it again what is the point
of taking more lashes you're just like
all right i'm gonna get this
[ __ ] later
absolutely sir you are the boss
i got my mind right got my
shaking the bush
walking it off boss walking it off
um all right bad luck
dear mr burr
what to do
when everything goes south for an
extended period of time so i am a 32
year old with quite a good track record
former semi-pro hockey player three
university degrees
in rather good shape and overall not
that ugly
and he got a sense of humor
you're crushing it one sentence in i
love this guy two sentences is however i
have had no luck with girls jobs or
health in the past 10 years i have had
almost every disease disease known to
man okay there is a little bit
padding in that story
i i have unbelievably bad luck with jobs
always when i get my dream job something
from outside comes and stops me getting
there this has happened three times now
and the last one was one of the classics
the company went to hiring to a hiring
freeze and let 25 percent of the
workforce go and girls well i can get
some but i just have no interactions
with girls with personalities i would
like
uh they are out there but if i meet them
it does not go
anywhere i love sports and now i have
been unable to train for a year and a
half due to a disease
heart problems plus virus
uh i am unable to do work
so there is that even if i would like to
get a job there is none available and i
am a [ __ ]
working in fi in the finance industry
i am sure i am not the only one to be in
this situation so my question for you is
how do you believe in your future if
everything's been [ __ ] so far please go
fornicate yourself
you're sincerely
ps english is not my first language so
please excuse me well that was pretty
impressive
um
all right so how do you continue um
thinking positively um it's a choice
you just have to decide to do it i mean
what else are you gonna do are you gonna
let it win
you can't let it win and everybody who's
been successful always has
you know they have all their stories
when they sit around
telling stories about you know after
they've been successful all they talk
about is the [ __ ] that they [ __ ] went
through which is most of panel if you li
if you watch a late night talk show
if a comic goes on he's not going to
talk about the time he killed he's going
to talk about the time he bombed the
time about he lost his agent the time
his [ __ ] tv show got cancelled all
the pain of that and all that because
you know it's funny
but the big thing is is when you're
sitting there watching it going this
person went through all of this [ __ ]
so i feel bad that you're going through
all that especially the health part
um
i don't know what kind of virus she had
but i mean not like if you told me i'd
[ __ ] know anything that's like i'm a
doctor obviously so
um
what i would do if i was you was i would
i would focus on what you can control
you can't work out but there's nothing
stopping you from eating perfectly
um
how about something low impact like yoga
like i don't
ever see where
light stretching
and eating as perfectly as you possibly
can
would ever be a detriment to your health
so that would be a step in the positive
direction
and um
as far as like your bad luck with women
to [ __ ] that dude [ __ ] that
there's no such thing you just keep you
just keep getting back what what what is
the worst they're gonna say no
who gives a [ __ ] they laugh at you
you're already laughing at yourself all
right you just become undeniable you
become unstoppable it's just not going
to beat you
all right
who knows who knows how long you're
going to be here who knows how long i'm
going to be here but like every year
you're [ __ ] living your life day to
day you can't let it beat you
that's basically it you make that
[ __ ] choice
now get out there in the second half
crush some ass do some yoga and eat some
goddamn beats
um
yeah that's what i would say i would
just [ __ ] refuse to let this thing
you know just do that that [ __ ] dave
day-to-day thing
you might win but not today
all right i'm tougher than you today go
[ __ ] yourself and i'm enjoying this day
there you go i would do that
and uh
i don't know and if you're going to be
around women don't have an angry energy
like me that is like raid
to women don't do that all right you
attract
psychos and uh it's just it's just not a
good situation so
anyways
all right 100 days without booze
hey bill ball sag
pillball saggins
parentheses i don't know i tried
all right quickly to the point i'm doing
a hundred days clean i love it inspired
by your podcast a while back i like the
whole deadline thing knowing there's
only x more days to go and stuff makes
it easier
uh makes it easier to do it i feel
better i'm not pissed off as much i'm
not i'm getting a handle on my money
this is all good things which is a lot
easier when you're not buying whiskey
slash rounds in brooklyn buzz
um and he further goes on to say so
thanks for setting a good example on how
to keep that [ __ ] in check
only problem is is it's kind of messing
up my game or what i thought was my game
which might have just been getting drunk
enough to think uh a six was a nine for
the night instead of practicing some
patience and self-control did you do the
100 days when you were
with nia or did you do even did you ever
do sober stint single i'm a single dude
in my 30s and i'm a writer so i don't
have an automatic social life unless i
go out at night basically that means up
till now i've met all my previous
girlfriends at bars or at shows but now
i feel like
if i'm sober and they're not
then isn't that kind of like taking
advantage i know exactly what you're
saying yeah uh like if a gal's got two
plus drinks in her and i'm not in the
same
rocking boat i'm just standing on the
deck watching everyone else swaying back
and forth it almost seems shady to be
picking up gals in other words how the
hell do you meet cool chicks
if you're taking a gentleman interlude
from the booze i know in the past you've
recommended like mixed gendered sports
and stuff just
wondering if uh you got any other
insights thanks and go uh i'm not even
gonna say it um
all right so judging by that
you're not athletic
because you already know what i
suggested so i would i would get
involved in something
else get involved in something dude if
you could somehow cut out booze and bars
out of your [ __ ] life at some point
it's a great thing get eight hours sleep
you get more [ __ ] done and then you
start doing uh
you know something else i don't know
what join a [ __ ] gym
join but join like a specific one like
you know they got like those rock
climbing gyms it's way more social
because it's like a specific thing that
everybody's into if you just go to the
treadmill elliptical weight thing you
know then everybody's got their [ __ ]
headphones on and [ __ ] but um
you know if it's something more like uh
like that rock climbing stuff or uh
i don't know riding a bike my shit's
always physically active i don't know
what else to do i mean i don't know what
other types of interaction things you
know what the [ __ ] you're supposed to do
but i respect the fact that you don't
like hitting on a woman when she's drunk
and you're sober yeah i don't like that
either that feels like some form of
sexual assault
if you end up hooking up with them you
know if they're all over you i don't
know i still was always like all right
well you know let me know what you think
tomorrow
you know after the [ __ ] uh hang over
there
right there boozy
um
i should [ __ ] take a day off man
i [ __ ] drank it up yesterday
last night ended up eating off a food
truck
got a super [ __ ]
deluxe burrito whatever the hell you
call it
horrific and i'm paying for it today
oh god damn day no energy stupid
[ __ ] stupid
why can't i stop
maybe i should join that rock climbing
gym
all right and there you go there's the
ads for this week
um
okay here we go here's another guy
laying off the boos
another guy laying
off the booze
billy buster of balls i'm a big fan and
an even bigger booze hound i'm a 47 year
old boozer with a good job successfully
raising my two young daughters myself
you recently went on a run of sobriety
that i admire can you talk more
on your [ __ ] epic podcast thank you
about how you did it and what types of
food you ate to help you replace the
sugar that your body missed without the
sweet
mother's milk of vodka thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself yeah dude you're addicted
you're addicted um to sugar
like most people like myself or whatever
so um what i've found
with food is
it's really all about that first night
you know if you you can eat well all day
on the first day of your diet and right
around four o'clock five o'clock in the
afternoon your body starts craving the
[ __ ] food that you've been eating either
something salty or sugary or any if you
can just [ __ ] push through that
you know drink plenty of water not a
dangerous level of water don't [ __ ]
make the walls of your cells [ __ ]
not even exist anymore is that what
happens you can literally die from
drinking too much water just drink water
big salad with the protein and then just
make yourself go to bed that white
knuckle at the first night
and then your body starts to get used to
that and after doing that for three days
you're on a nice track
and um
to help you along if you get that um
hey nia what is it dark chocolate
yeah if you get that dark chocolate
um
it's weird like you just eat like a
little corner of it
it feels way more dense than like milk
chocolate but it's not nearly as sugary
i don't know if there's any sugar in it
but it kind of
keeps that sugar uh thing at bay
and um that's kind of a way you can kind
of cheat your way through it but
what's cool about your body is if you
actually feed it healthy food it craves
healthy food like you'll actually get
psyched
for a salad with some chicken on it or
some [ __ ] believe it or not i never
thought it was going to be possible but
i i would say
you know you got to be careful with the
uh obviously with the salad dressings
you know
um and people always when they talk
about calories and [ __ ] they'll always
say like you might as well have had a
big mac i i 100 disagree with that
um it might even if the caloric intake
is equal there's nothing worse than a
[ __ ] big mac because at the end of
the day if you had a giant [ __ ] salad
with a ton of calories dressing on top
of it you still ate a [ __ ] salad
where of a big mac you just ate a big
mac
all right
and [ __ ] all you no-necked [ __ ]
trainers who are now going to question
that that makes sense to me and i don't
give a [ __ ] about your degree
in [ __ ] salad dressing um
yeah so just white knuckle it for the
first uh three i need to do that like
i'm trying to get back into working out
i've been so [ __ ] busy and i'm
forcing myself to go downstairs
because my body's saying i don't want to
do it i don't want to do it you drank
last night you ate that [ __ ] food let's
[ __ ] relax and eat more [ __ ] food and
i'm just going to force myself to go
down there and all i got to do is that
first set of push-ups the blood gets
going and then the body's like yeah yeah
i want to do this i want to do this and
then you know half hour lady like thank
god i did this and it's [ __ ] over
so uh another great thing especially a
guy your age you're almost you're a
little a year older than me take a
[ __ ] walk at night hey take a [ __ ]
walk i'm telling you just walk around
the block
at a nice leisurely pace
you know put on your walkman or whatever
the [ __ ] you listen to now
whatever the hell you call it your phone
your transistor radio
listen to some music walk around the
block um
it's great you burn cat calories you're
not beating on your joints
you know you burn like 100 200 calories
just walking around the block right
before you go to bed nice big glass of
[ __ ] water
go to bed and then start your day i like
[ __ ] oatmeal
with bananas and raisin in it no milk no
brown sugar none of that [ __ ] that's
gonna send your body back get you back
on the smack [ __ ] that it's a big lump
of [ __ ] that's good for you
sits right in your belly it fills you up
have a [ __ ] apple for a snack and
then i don't know peanut butter and
jelly sandwich or a turkey sandwich lean
turkey sandwich and you're on your way
and then you're all the way to four
o'clock
then all you got to do is the salad and
the protein and just shove that [ __ ]
sometimes i'll do the salad at lunch
just to get it out of the [ __ ] way
just gotta get it all the way just
[ __ ] do that
then it's the end of the night again
drink your giant thing of water take
another [ __ ] walk and then your
body's just into that
and then you'll drop weight and then the
hardest [ __ ] thing is once your body
gets used to that and you get bored of
that [ __ ]
or you start lying to yourself like i
could have a big mac i've been doing
i've been you know i'm gonna treat
myself i've been doing well and you're
basically i've tried you're treating
yourself to the heroine again
and it's gonna be in you for three days
and you gotta be really careful after
you eat like [ __ ] for the next three
days because there's that demon is back
in you
go get get a pizza get some ice cream
but blah blah blah i'm telling you at
least that's how my body works
um
anyway so good luck man you're making
some smart choices there all right
threesome problems
oh god i want this guy's life it's
[ __ ] great
threesome hey nia you want to come in
for this one
neato
well you're all stuffy come on that'll
be funny
next week okay
all right threesome problems greetings
billy boy long time listener first time
caller
question mark as they used to say i
realize many if not most guys would love
to have my problems but nonetheless it's
caused me some headaches so i thought
i'd ask an [ __ ] like you for his two
cents well you've come to the right
place
if you're looking for an a-hole my wife
of years
is very much bisexual and we have
brought other women into our
relationship since we started dating
all right so
okay
is that still technically a marriage i'm
not trying to be a prude here but like
um
all right so
you guys are like
friends
it's [ __ ] great
this is great this [ __ ] guy how the
[ __ ] did you pull this off nah not like
we i guess because his wife's bisexual
anyway it's not like we do this every
friday night but since we are both very
sexual people and the fact that she has
no interest in screwing another dude
it's just a win-win
yeah you [ __ ] what what is your
problem he
you're taking up
valuable time on this podcast for other
people who actually have problems he
goes here is the rub so to speak
nudged
most of the girls
have been hookups more or less and that
neither of us had any real emotional
attachment to them yeah you got it i
would think you'd have to do it that way
we're gonna bang your neighbor and then
have to see her for the rest of the time
you're like how are you remember that
time i diddled you
and then my wife was doing that other
thing to you
no we don't want to do it again we just
wanted to do it to you once
have a nice day ethel
um while that sounds crass all three
sometimes even four
once five
five at once all of us were consulting
adults etcetera etcetera how did you
have a a two on five
did you go you must you guys must be
swingers
where did you go down to the y hey we
got we got next we got next
standing outside an orgy
um anyways he said but there is one good
friend of my wife that has found her way
into our bed off and on for a few years
now usually after all of us have had one
too many cocktails yeah dude
all right
yeah you're dancing with the devil here
again so far so good except that this
lady
let's call her jenny jenny i got your
number
you wanna bang my wife
um so far so good it's just okay we'll
call her jenny is just
as into
each of us personally as she is into us
as a couple that is she is down to screw
each one of us individually
now this person right here is the real
winner in all of this because you know
she's not in a relationship this person
she's the one getting her cake and
eating it she has nothing to [ __ ]
lose
um anyways
she says while my wife was away on
business ah
i gave in and did the deed
jenny insists that a my wife would not
consider this cheating and b even if she
did
she that is jenny would never tell her
part of the problem is that like i
mentioned my wife has zero interest in
other dudes and being the ex frat guy
that i am
i really would not be jealous if she
informed me
that she slept with a girl while on a
business trip
but at the same time my gut is telling
me she'd be very angry and very hurt if
she learned that i slept with jenny one
or
one-on-one in her absence jenny i have
had sex three times in my wife's absence
yeah dude you're kind of having an
affair right now
i feel like i am about the absolute
limit at which i can admit all to my
wife that is
after 4 5 6 8 12 whatever times it is no
longer a new problem and is simply an
affair should i just come clean now
considering that this is not exactly
your run-of-the-mill affair thanks my
man
um i don't know dude i would i would
immediately stop banging jenny on the
side
um you know what dude
your relationship is uh
complex to say the least and uh there's
going to be some security issues
there's going to be some breaches in
security so you had a breach in security
she's not going to say anything you
don't say anything you know
you basically [ __ ] this woman that your
wife is [ __ ] she just wasn't there so
i don't know what that is uh that sounds
like a uh that sounds like offsetting
penalties
no not really because your wife is the
other team um
i don't know for i i would i would stop
banging her and you did it three [ __ ]
times i don't know if you want to say
that that's your call if you want to say
something say something
you know that's going to be a [ __ ] storm
and your wife is probably gonna think
you know their vengeful
uh sex so
do the math on that one if she's gonna
get you back i don't think she's getting
with jenny
she's getting with lenny oh
sorry apologize
apologize for the pun um is that a pun i
don't know what it is um so there you go
that is the uh that's the podcast for
this week everybody
uh j-e-t-s jets jets tonight playing i
don't know who i don't know who i don't
know what i haven't watched him yet this
year but i am predicting the new england
patriots are going to go 500 against the
jets 500 against the bills 500 against
the dolphins maybe we'll beat one of
them twice
um
i think all three of them might have got
a little better and i just think that we
get a little worse
i don't know i just uh there's just
something about i don't know letting the
raiders hang around that long the
raiders
no disrespect to the greatest [ __ ]
emblem in all of sports
but they are what they are
and have been what they've been for this
[ __ ] long so
i don't know what to tell you um anyways
other than i'm looking forward to it i'm
trying to be a [ __ ] this year
and uh rooting against teams and all
that [ __ ] it really kills a lot of my
enjoyment of it i know it's funny for
you guys and that type of [ __ ] but i'm
just really busy i don't i don't time to
[ __ ] hate this year
you